[Musik]
die justiz ist überlastet die verfahren
dauern immer länger das
sicherheitsgefühl des bürgers leidet wer
am rechtsstaat der wirt unrecht ernten
sagt man dass hier in phoenix persönlich
jugendrichter andreas müller was erleben
sie denn der täglichen praxis sind diese
vorwürfe berechtigt schöne spruch finde
ich aber erst recht spart wird unrichtig
unrecht erhalten man sieht es in der
parteienlandschaft
diese vorwürfe sind teilweise berechtigt
nicht unbedingt berechtigt in jedem fall
was das gros angeht der arbeit die
justiz noch ganz gut aber sobald es
schwieriger wird soweit ermittelt werden
muss sobald es um haft geht sobald es um
wirklich herrscht heftige geschichten
die dauern die verfahren unheimlich lang
in polen eine zahl von acht monaten das
ist quatsch sie müssen immer und das
wird auch nie so gesagt sehen zunächst
ermittelt die polizei
die polizei ermittelt bei einfachen
geschichten ladendiebstahl gittern
schnell aber wenn es ein bisschen
komplizierter es geht es nicht schnell
denn dauert es ewig lange und dann haben
die keine leute dann kann es schon mal
sechs sieben monate geht dann geht es
zur neuen belasteten staatsanwaltschaft
und da bleiben die akten wieder liegen
und dann kommen irgendwann mal im
gericht an ja und dann ist das gericht
auch noch überlastet so und dann kommen
die zeugen bei milan nach anderthalb
jahren oder teilweise zwei jahren und
verstehen die welt nicht mehr und wenn
sie die welt nicht mehr verstehen warum
ist das jetzt erst dran ja dann glauben
sie nicht mehr in den rechtsstaat und
den wählen sie möglicherweise an mal von
den politischen gerade noch mal weggehen
gehen wir noch mal zum gericht was sind
denn ihre persönlichen erfahrungen
wir haben ja tatsächlich das gefühl das
subjektive gefühl des bürgers der sagt
ich fühle mich nicht wirklich sicher die
kriminalstatistik gibt das nicht wieder
das muss man auch sagen die zahlen sind
anders
auch bei der jugendkriminalität aber
dennoch hat er das gefühl vielleicht
greift sogar die polizei schnell zu aber
dann dauert es ewig bis jemand vorhatte
das ist das richtig das gefühl der
bürger ist so ich sie das auch
tagtäglich zunächst einmal ist es so es
ist zurückgegangen ja ich würde es auch
mal positiv sehen jugendkriminalität ich
wird hier wurde hier heute als jugend
und strafrichter angekündigt ich habe
früher nur jugendrecht gemacht jetzt
mache ich hälfte hälfte also ist es ein
zeichen dafür dass wir im
jugendstrafverfahren weniger fälle haben
so einfach und jetzt muss man gucken die
kriminalität geht zurück aber sie ist
nach wie vor natürlich auf einem hohen
niveau
und wenn der bürger opfer wird dann
würde er natürlich ein schnelles
verfahren für sich als opfer er möchte
den schutz des staates und da braucht es
drei organisationen das als die polizei
das ist die staatsanwaltschaft und die
gerichte und hier hat man tatsächlich in
den letzten jahren jahrzehnten nicht
aufgepasst gegen alle warnungen der ober
gerichtspräsidenten gegen der wahl gegen
die warnung der ganz normalen richter
ich kann mich in brandenburg daran
erinnern vor 34 jahren sind hunderte von
richtern vor dem landtag marschiert habe
gesagt stattet uns besser aus macht
irgendwas ja und merkt euch wir werden
älter und älter
die justiz geht langsam aber richtung
kollaps ich werde schon wieder leute das
ist ja gewohnt weil das emotionen
ich war früher richter mit haut und
haaren heute ich bin 58 jahre alt schäme
ich mich manchmal dafür im bei welchem
arbeitgeber ich arbeite und ich
entschuldige mich ganz oft bei menschen
die formel stehen im namen der justiz
und sage ich tut mir leid dass ich
diesen arbeitgeber noch aber das ist
auch das mitleid mit dem opfer aber
natürlich aber er hat das gefühl da ist
etwas passiert ich bin ein opfer einer
straftat und jetzt passiert erst mal gar
nichts weil das gericht zu lange braucht
war die wege zu lange sind weil die
infrastruktur nicht mehr
es ist aber ein ganz ungutes und
schlechtes gefühl für den bürger in der
gesellschaft ja gar nicht hört sich aber
das hat die politik wird gespart auf
allen ebenen ja haben sie häuser
verscherbelt haben diesen test gemacht
haben sich nur keine neuen wege überlegt
wie man kann man die justiz entlasten
sie haben nicht für nachwuchs gesorgt da
fangen sie jetzt erst anfang des jahres
2018 haben den justiz packt gemacht 2000
neue stellen für richter und
staatsanwälte
ich glaube da etwa uns im kiez ist noch
teil eingestellt wurden und die die
reinkommen
ja ich weiß gerade im landgerichtsbezirk
frankfurt oder waren drei staatsanwälte
sind alle wieder weg weil man sich
verheizen und die alten die sind bereits
verheizt
das heißt da ist irgendwann auch ein so
großer frust dass sie sagen ich sehe
diesen berg von akten und irgendwie muss
ich mich durch arbeiten aber das dauert
dann eben und ich mache es nur noch mit
zusammengebissenen zähnen also der frust
ist sehr sehr groß wie wird der sich
denn dann auch im verfahren ich ja auch
bei ihnen persönlich möchte dieses
verfahren denn aussagen sie waren gott
dann machen wir es eben jetzt serie
eingestellt
es wird mehr eingestellt wenn sie die
sachen haben die drei jahre liegen aus
irgendwelchen gründen weil sie was weiß
ich dies oder jenes nicht geschafft
haben nicht bei mir insgesamt immer
insgesamt stellt man eher ein weil ja
das aber sie müssen ja auch sehen
die strafverfahren sind ja nicht nur für
die opfer da sondern auch für die
angeklagt und leute die jahrelang auf
ihre verfahren warten sind ja auch
bestraft wir haben ja auch wir haben ja
auch werte und das sind zum beispiel
zügige verfahren beschleunigungsgebot
und und und und wenn angeklagter drei
jahren der steht ja irgendwie was weiß
ich
eine kleinigkeit gemacht haben dann hat
er schon dreijährige vor gezittert was
mit ihm passiert gibt es aber auch ja
und das wäre ja ein beispiel dafür dass
es schlecht läuft
sagen wir mal die forderungen danach
wenn jemand eine straftat begeht sogar
bei einer ordnungswidrigkeit sollte
eigentlich hinter der nächsten ecke
jemand stehen der sache was hast du da
gemacht
so 20 euro oder was auch immer jetzt
haben sie aber verfahren die dauern
jahre lang die werden wie sie selber
sagen im zweifelsfall auch verschleppt
auch von den von den anwälten
verschleppen da hat doch jemand das
gefühl auch margot doch mal hat die
nächste geschichte und ich stand immer
als jugendrichter für schnelle verfahren
jetzt in berlin gab es die mir das
modell nach gießen hey sich ja
neuköllner modell das ist alles nicht
weiter verfolgt worden ja und weil
mittlerweile ich kann ihn einfach sagen
auch wenn das ich habe so ein bisschen
aufgegeben ich mache natürlich noch die
die sachen die wirklich richtig gut sind
ja da stecke ich auch noch mit herzblut
drin aber insgesamt ist es einfach nicht
mehr so wie es sein sollte eine
ordnungswidrigkeit wenn sie bei rot
fahren ja oder gehen irgendwie da
kriegen sie ganz schnell ihre strafe
aber bei den dicken geschichten da
dauert es niemandem beispiel was mit ihm
was mich wütend macht ja sexy
kinderpornografie die
landeskriminalämter brauchen ewig um das
auszuwerten in brandenburg ja der werden
computer beschlagnahmt und so weiter da
haben sie die beweise der liegen wenn es
gibt keine auswertung
also ich habe neulich gehört drei jahre
und acht monate bis das überhaupt
angeklagt werden kann
und er hat dieser staat einfach
unheimlich viel
ich benutze mal meine worte scheiße
gebaut ja sie haben immer schön gespart
gegen alle warnungen und jetzt haben sie
die ehre antun die ernte ist einfach die
ja dass die menschen darauf hoffen dass
irgendwelche jemand das besser macht und
das wird nicht so schnell passieren weil
sie haben ja die stellen angesprochen
und auch die infrastruktur angesprochen
auch heute wenn man ein verfahren hat
bei gericht faxt man das noch so fern
dass diese geräte überhaupt noch
irgendwo gibt sie verdrehen die augen
nachvollziehbar
es hat man im juni eine umfrage der
rheinischen post gegeben zum thema
sicherheit und interessanterweise sagen
da 66 prozent der befragten wir brauchen
mehr polizei wir wollen mehr
ordnungsdienst
haben sagen 52 prozent auf 50 sagen mehr
videoüberwachung aber ganz spannend ist
83 sind für eine null toleranz strategie
ist das eigentlich schon diese
rückmeldung darüber ist so viele so geht
in richtung polizeistaat so
durchgreifend hattest du ich aber dass
das was ich bis jetzt rollen macht in
nordrhein westfalen ist ja erfolgreich
was ist einer erfolgreichen sind wir
durch die nordrhein westfälischen städte
gehen sie mal durch köln gehen sind wir
durch deuten und wo ist denn da
irgendwie ne in politik erfolgreich ja
ganz offenbar sind die clowns in
nordrhein-westfalen verunsichern so will
ich ja hierher natürlich verunsichert
ja was ist verunsichert haben sie mal
nen plan boss gesprochen wie ich nicht
aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen ist
sondern völlig verunsichert ist er wird
in seiner häuser sonstwo haben und ob ja
irgendwie ein paar das ist symbolpolitik
und diese symbol politik führt
insbesondere dazu das ist gut also der
vor zehn jahren schon haben wir davor
gewarnt ja da muss rein gegangen werden
aber es führt letztendlich dazu dass man
gesetze macht wie meinetwegen die
vermögensabschöpfung dh man kann die
eigentumswohnung kassieren und und und
das hat unser ehemaliger justizminister
heute der außenminister herr maas ja der
hat mal ein vermögensabschöpfung gesetz
gemacht und wohin geht das dass jeder
ist gericht jetzt genau wie auch bei
jugendlichen und so weiter genau
feststellen muss wie hoch weil der
schaden
das führt zu weiteren längeren verfahren
dass herr wollte sollte auf die
organisierte kriminalität ziehen
man hat aber alles getroffen damit das
heißt man hat genau das erreicht was man
gar nicht erreichen haben nämlich einen
stillstand der justiz was kann man
machen
wir haben wenn wir sagen die
kriminalstatistik sagt es ist eigentlich
ein rückgang festzustellen aber dennoch
immer wieder den straftäter bei ihnen
vor gericht stehen
sie müssen über das verfahren
entscheiden sie merken selber welche
probleme sie in der infrastruktur im
justizapparat
was muss ich denn dann ändern aus ihrer
sicht eine ganze menge das was er schon
seit jahren angemahnt wurde gefangen an
bei der personalausstattung bei der
polizei muss es mehr
pauli sei ausstattung geben dann müssen
mehr leute an die arbeit gebracht wird
und es müssen gute leute sind und wir
müssen gut bezahlt werden das gleiche
gilt bei staatsanwaltschaften und
gerichte man musste einfach mal
überlegen in den nächsten zehn jahren
verlassen etwa 10.000 staatsanwälte und
richter ja ihre büros da muss aufgebaut
werden da muss nachgebaut werden
das sind leute ja die sind wie ich 58 60
er gibt krankheiten die haben nicht mehr
diese kraft wie junge leute
wenn man da jetzt nicht sofort ran geht
dann wird's ein kollaps geben und da
sind nicht leere versprechungen
angezeigt und so weiter und dann gibt es
natürlich die möglichkeit mal zu
überlegen was wie man mit der
symbolpolitik so alles anrichtet da wird
passiert irgendwas irgendwo und am
nächsten tag kommt irgendjemand da
machen ein neues gesetz aber diese neue
gesetze müssen auch umgesetzt werden und
die richter müssen geschult werden und
sie müssen es auch im rahmen ihrer
arbeitskraft noch schaffen können und
daran denkt man nicht das heißt denn
irgendwie kein besonderer
personalaufwand wir haben viel
opferschutz reingebracht wir haben aber
nicht dafür den richtern die zeit
gegeben
ja es gibt ja pensen ordnung das heißt
jedes verfahren ich kannte ja ihre
vorträge halten müssen auch mal
zwischendurch fragen 130 verletzung 180
minuten
und wenn der angeklagte nicht geständig
ist brauchen sie zwei tage das gleiche
kriegen sie beim sexuellen missbrauch
der brauchen sie drei tage ja wenn er
nicht geständig ist und also so werden
auch unheimlich viele deals gemacht ja
im gericht
das zu bestaunen das irgendwie noch
hinzu haben sie denn am tag da welcher
vor
ich habe im jahr etwa 5 600 verfahren
und wenn in diesen 5 600 verfahren
meinetwegen als schwierige fälle stecken
denn verzögert sich
die anwälte sind ändern
tage eigentlich im grunde genommen sind
die stärker ist die große ja das ist
auch der vorwurf in der bevölkerung
das ist der vorfall in der bevölkerung
ja wenn man bilder sie dir wo
meinetwegen in tiergarten irgendwie die
leute über einen gang schreien können
die sanieren so etwas passiert irgendwie
nicht wirklich ist ja also bei mir gehen
dann raus in dieser personalie her
ja und jetzt sofort weil man da noch die
möglichkeit hat ja das ist das ist das
was bei der bevölkerung ankommen das
macht mich ja irgendwie auch krank krank
ist ein stichwort für die kollegin
nämlich frau sich die sie angesprochen
haben eben sie ist durch ein suizid aus
dem leben 2000 ist jetzt ein anderes
thema
sie war hoch frustriert und es hat sich
im juni in einer oder können sie die
lage nachvollziehen von jemandem der
täglich mit diesen dingen zu tun
und der sagt an einem punkt jetzt kann
ich nicht mehr ja sehr wohl ich bin auch
bald so weit
ja weil man ja sieht da kommt immer mehr
rein wir im amtsgericht per neuer
brauchen meine zwölf richter wird eine
abgezogen und der elfte fehlt das geht
über jahre
ja wir kriegen keine neue weil sie
keiner haben weil die justizverwaltung
in den ländern nicht aufgepasst das gilt
auch in baden württemberg in berlin
und so weitere verfahren werden immer
komplizierter schwieriger aber auf der
anderen seite hat man keine personal
kraft und das frustriert natürlich wenn
ich wenn ich mal ich hab mir das
beispiel jacken es muss also
kinderpornografie und dreieinhalb jahre
bis es zu einer auswertung kommt und sie
kriegen die akte auf dem tisch was
denken sie
das darf doch nicht wahr sein das ist
jetzt kein missbrauch aber es ist
kinderpornografie
und dann gibt es natürlich die
möglichkeiten der haben gefragt was
können wir machen ja wir können eine
ganze menge machen wir müssen erstmal
entschlacken
was bringen wir eigentlich vor gericht
womit beschäftigen wir die polizei
fangen wir an mit fahren
ohne fahrschein also schwarzfahren was
wir alles schon mal gemacht haben sie
bestimmt noch nie aber noch einmal so
eben mal kurz sie die zwei stationen
können wir ja dann sind sie in
straftäter nach bundesrepublikanischen
recht warum muss das eine straftat sein
12 prozent ja in den deutschen klassen
sitzen wegen schwarzfahren dort die
haben schon genügend probleme damit dass
jede inkassobüros mit geld versorgen
müssen bei dir die dann ab die ihre
forderung abtreten an große firmen und
so weiter warum müssen wir die in den
knast button
sie haben ein beispiel nämlich das
beispiel cannabis da sagen sie warum
keine freigabe weil wir kriminalisieren
dinge die man eigentlich nicht
kriminalisieren sollte und wir
überlasten uns quasi selber die hände
flüssigkeit aus ihrer sicht freunden
hier richtig ist mein lieblingsthema ja
noch hier kommen natürlich kann er
bisher rege ich mich aufregen ich habe
jetzt auch in diesem monat habe ich noch
mehrere cannabis fälle statt eine
kampagne des deutschen verbandes die da
hingeht und sagt dieses gesetz dass
cannabis verbot ist verfassungswidrig
nach meiner überzeugung ist es auch
nachher überzeugung aus ihrer
überzeugung sein und das einfach ja ein
gesetz muss ein ziel haben was man auch
erreichen kann und ist sie war schlicht
und einfach man wollte irgendwie
cannabis ein der mit den 70er jahren das
war der inbegriff des bösen rauschgiftes
hat man gar nicht geschafft dass haben
wir mehr gekämpft und heute griffen noch
mehr und jugendliche griffen auch gut du
musst es geeignet sollen dieses gesetz
ist nicht geeignet weil alle kirchen
überall
ja er muss es erforderlich sein wofür
erforderlich cannabis hat die gefahr ja
die weit unterhalb von alkohol und
sonstigen drogen ist das ist ein indem
er mildesten drogen dieser welt hat die
vero festgestellt es ist nicht
zielführend es ist nicht geeignet es ist
nicht erforderlich und jetzt ist auch
nicht der verhältnismäßig hier wird in
diesem bereich mit kanonen auf spatzen
geschossen
ja hier hat man schneller erfolge man
geht durch die parks findet irgendwie
ein paar junge leute meistens studenten
der nachwuchs von morgen kontrolliert
die 1 gramm
und dann hat man wieder ein
erfolgreiches ermittlungsverfahren
abgeschlossen
diese ganzen geschichten die braucht
nicht vor gericht aber das sind ja nur
die kleinen die großen es gibt ganze
strafkammer die sich monatelang mit gros
an das sind die leute die selber züchten
ja und dir in irgendwie den schwarzmarkt
versorgen beschäftigen das ist alles
völlig überflüssig also wenn sie mal ein
bisschen einschlagen würden unsere
gesetze und nicht permanent aufblähen
dann könnten sie auch hier einsparen
wenn 200 polizisten ja damit beschäftigt
sind irgendwo ein konzert ja vorher alle
jungen leute durchsuchen und meiner
jugend war es nicht so wir könnten
locker hingehen halten unser peace in
der tasche ja aber heute wird das alles
kontrolliert bis zum gehtnichtmehr
und dann haben sie ein ergebnis haben
sie zwei gefunden die hatten irgendwie
ein paar gramm hasch dabei jetzt sagen
viele
diese cannabis geschichte ist deswegen
so schlimm war dass ein einstieg ist in
harte drogen jetzt muss man dazu wissen
auch ihre reaktion die jetzt
wahrscheinlich kommen wird der ich merke
es schon
man muss wissen sie selber haben ein
vater verloren der alkoholkrank war hier
sie haben einen bruder verloren den
ältesten bruder weil er rauschgift
süchtig wahrheit ich habe den ich
verloren nicht weil er rauschgift
süchtig war ich habe den verloren weil
der staat ihn aufgrund von cannabis
kriminalisierung in den knast gepackt
hat und sie sagen der würde noch leben
wenn das nicht kriminalisiert worden
wäre
da bin ich mir heute absolut sicher wenn
wir eine andere drogen politik hätten
die weltweit übrigens gefordert wird
aber nicht nur im cannabis bereich
sondern auch in anderen bereichen
dann hätten wir weniger kriminalität ja
wir hatten weniger leute die wir die
knäste packen immer cannabis in den
letzten fünf jahrzehnten sind weit über
eine halbe million überwiegend jungen
menschen in deutsche netze gegangen und
also mit den ganzen strafverfahren dabei
und und und weil sie im umgang mit
cannabis gepflegt haben das hat man auch
bruder immer wir haben heroin abhängige
und so weiter die gehen rein in die
knesset und wieder heraus warum soll
denn warum soll das gemacht werden oder
junge frauen die sich prostituieren
die sind nun mal süchtig oder krank aber
dann müssen wir sie wie krank oder
süchtig behandeln und dann geben wir
ihnen ihre rezepte und ihr rezept zum
beispiel feder von meint wäre heroin auf
krankenschein wo die hingehen könnten
und sagen hier nein stattdessen kriegen
die ersatzdrogen die wesentlich
schlimmer sind weil er der stadt dafür
kein dealer sollen und zurück zur
einstiegsdroge
bereits 1994 hat das höchste deutsche
gericht festgestellt dass vertritt
weltweit kein wissenschaftler mehr
dort kommt er wissen woher wir sind ja
etwa ich weiß - in jünger aus so ich
will sollen nicht zu nahe treten
christiane f christiane f hat das
gedanken die gedankenwelt unserer ganzen
gesellschaft geprägt nur langsam aber
sicher wenn christiane f dieses arme
mädchen hat als erstes gekifft wie
übrigens viele viele andere auch aber
sie haben auch zuerst alkohol sie haben
zuerst nikotin genommen und so hat diese
bevölkerung dann gedacht wer einmal hast
der wird hier ruine die zahlen sprechen
dagegen ja mit den ganzen jungs mit dem
ich gekifft habe oder wird sagten damals
gehasst wir waren ja die us brüder
ich weiß nicht ob sie auch rasch bruder
waren so im kreis gesessen sondern die
die das spiel ohne ball ging wiederum
gegeben und so weiter ich weiß wenigsten
wovon ich spreche ja die sollten wir die
nächste diskussion im deutschen
bundestag alle mal aufzeigen wer schon
mal gekifft hat ja na ja da ist ja auch
immer mal was gefunden wurde aber all
gesehen haben meist jaja kokain aber
abgesehen davon wollen sie ja
bundesverfassungsgericht anrufen und das
mal klären lassen wie groß sind denn die
chancen dass so etwas funktionieren wird
also ich will das weil ich es einer zeit
finde ich brauche natürlich fälle
ich werde in diesem monat noch den einen
oder anderen fall nur mit cannabis
behandeln dann ist es so dass man ja
auch gucken muss das will denn der
angeklagte will der unbedingt ein
langjähriges verfahren oder dies das
schnelle ende was will die
staatsanwaltschaft und dann ist es
abhängig davon wie es so läuft aber de
facto bin ich der meinung wenn ich den
nächsten fall habe der pass kitas link
noch karlsruhe weil meine
rechtsauffassung deswegen muss ich so
das so sagen war jetzt könnten hier
leute sagen ich bin gefangen
der ist ja befangen er ist ja für der es
ja geht nein rechtsauffassung führt nie
zu befangenheit ja die rechtsauffassung
muss sogar dargelegt werden die
deutschen richter sind durch unsere
grundgesetz väter und die 4 grundgesetz
mütter verpflichtet wurde nach artikel
hunde alle gesetze die sie anwenden
müssen darauf zu überprüfen ob sie
verfassungsgemäß sind und wenn nicht
dann haben sie nicht nur das recht
sondern auch die pflicht das höchste
deutsche gericht anzurufen das höchste
deutsche gericht hat seit 15 jahren
nicht mehr über die frage debattiert ob
die kriminalisierung noch zeitgemäß ist
ob sie noch erforderlich ist wir könnten
ganze kriminalitäts standpunkte
widerstand punkten stand also orte
mining görlitzer park wird in köln ebert
platz und in hamburg und so weiter
befriedigend wenn wir statt den deal an
irgendwelchen guten unternehmern mit
jugendschutz versehen ja kleine coffee
shops geben würden wo sie cannabis
verkaufen wird was in holland üblich ist
doch mal zu der situation nochmal zu der
situation eines jugend richters der ja
ganz am anfang möglicherweise einer
karriere einer kriminellen karriere
steht wenn jemand bei ihnen das erste
mal vor ihnen steht
dann sagen sie da muss auch der knast
mal her also es geht nicht darum immer
toleranz zu üben sondern knast ist auch
wichtig also die möglichst hohe strafe
ist auch wichtig
diejenigen zu zeigen damit sie nicht das
gefühl haben neuer gut in dem falle
komme ich nochmal ich habe ja so zwei
seiten das wir steht ja oftmals keiner
habe schon ziemlich hart durchgegriffen
und das ist auch manchmal richtig das
geht über schnelligkeit in dieser
schnelligkeit geht diesen diesem ganzen
diesem ganzen system ja verloren
deswegen bin ich ja was zu frustriert
und da habe ich aber auch irgendwann
vorjahre in meinem buch geschrieben das
nicht mehr auf dem markt das gibt es
vielleicht noch irgendwo im antiquariat
ja habe ich zum beispiel angemahnt es
muss fallen netz werden wenn junge leute
meinetwegen berlin-brandenburg ja immer
wieder von der bei der polizei auffallen
dann muss ich das wissen solche
vernetzung das sind einfache geschichten
haben wir bis heute nicht
ich habe es im register kommt dann immer
irgendjemanden sagt datenschutz stadt
opferschutz ja das habe ich damals im
justizministerium
das hatte ich kann ihn einfach mal so
ein paar fälle sagen ja was mich auch
frustriert ich weiß ich habe ja meine
ich habe ja unbegleitete junge leute die
hingekommen sind vor ein paar jahren die
überwiegende mehrheit wunderbare tolle
sich entwickelnde menschen für diese
gesellschaft und dann gibt es da ein 23
dabei aber wir machen immer wieder
straftaten und dann kommen die bei mir
an machen die in berlin habe ich habe
drei kleinigkeiten lade ich die polizei
dazu und dann kommen die polizei aalen
freuen sich schon ein richtiger müller
greift hart durch
geht aber nicht weil ich das futter
dafür nicht habe das nicht in
irgendwelchen abteilungen der berliner
staatsanwaltschaft
und da werden sie wütend sie wissen
genau diese paar dient das nicht richtig
machen sollte man schnell raus greifen
das gleiche habe ich mit deutschen
rechtsradikalen gemacht mit jungen
leuten die immer wieder getreten
damals hatte ich aber noch die kraft die
kraft um zu kämpfen
aber mittlerweile ist das system immer
schlimmer geworden man hat immer mehr
drauf gekriegt und drauf gekriegt und
drauf wir haben jetzt habe ich noch an
den wochenenden durchgearbeitet
das schaffe ich
und was dieser stadt von den richtern
verlangt ist sophie sie müssen
einstellen einstellen einstellen im
staatsanwaltschaft wesen einstellen ja
und sie müssen sie müssen die gesetze
mal durchforsten was macht sinn ja opfer
brauchen den schutz des staates und zwei
den schnellen schutz und jetzt die
überleitung warum auf der einen seite
mal hat und auf der anderen seite für
die legalisierung von cannabis
während bei den opfern die geschaffen
wurden durch individualität in denen sie
getreten wohl in dem sie das nasenbein
kaputt gemacht hat ist es beim cannabis
so dass der staat tagtäglich opfer
schafft indem sie junge menschen
20-25 kriminalisieren durchsuchen an den
führerschein abnehmen und so weit indem
sie leute in den knast stecken ohne sinn
und verstand in dem sie darüber hinaus
die möglichkeiten schaffen das in
irgendwelchen parks gedealt wird mit
cannabis überwiegend mit cannabis das
hätten wir ja gar nicht aber sie
brauchen das hier auch teilweise um
lohnt oder law & order der londoner ist
immer gut an sie halten das alles sehr
stark für sowohl politisch wie sie eben
noch unklar da wir greifen durch aber
sie sagen ja insgesamt verschlechtert
sich da etwas wenn wir noch mal auf frau
sah sich zurückkommen ist ihre situation
die sehr schwierig war sie waren sehr
sie waren ja auch in behandlung nach
ihrem tod weil sie sich möglicherweise
ja auch mit vielen identifiziert haben
was sie gemacht hat ist ihre situation
jetzt so dass sie sagen im grunde
genommen wurde ist am liebsten
hinschmeißen wir sie so hart an
ja aber wenn schon so leute wie ich habe
immer gedacht so bis 68 fall irgendwann
tot auf dem richtertisch um achse zu
schönes habe aber mittlerweile ist es so
in dieser justiz
dass man einst sehr sehr frustriert ist
es ist so ja es ist so wenn man den
opfern nicht gerecht werden kann den
täter nicht gerecht werden kann um wenn
man sieht dass trotz dieser mahnung ja
ich sage jetzt auch spd linke in
brandenburg ja mensch gerade linke sind
dafür da dass der kleine bürger
geschützt wird ja der kann sich nicht so
wären und er braucht es einen
rechtsstaat der funktioniert damit der
kleine bürger auch rechter wir haben das
nicht mehr so und das ist sie und wenn
die jetzt nicht in den nächsten jahren
massiv den rechtsstaat rechtsstaat rede
von rechtsstaat ausbauen
dann wird es einen unrechtsstaat geben
weil nämlich dann die law and order
leute ihre argumentation immer mehr
durchbringen und durchbringen können und
wir haben da hier was weiß ich den
rauschgift umschlagplatz da müssen wir
schwer rein dann wird jeder bürger
kontrolliert und so das will ich nicht
also brauchen wir eine starke
unabhängige rechtsstaatliche justiz mit
vernünftigen personal und wir müssen auf
der anderen seite gucken wo macht es
sinn menschen in dieser gesellschaft zu
verfolgen um dem cannabis bereich müssen
sich mal überlegen ja verfolgen wir ja
bald ein zehntel der
bundesrepublikanischen bevölkerung ein
zehntel oder leute mal die gekifft haben
in den letzten jahren die kiffen ja alle
sie haben gesagt sie sind sie zeit haben
christa ja aber ich muss ich muss sie
sind christ und da muss man ja auch eine
gewisse sich gezogen
ja ja auch gesagt sie sind dann nach dem
christlichen namen haben sie noch
hoffnung weil das ist ein zeichen von
religiosität hoffnungen der wenn ich
hier wieder eingeladen werden irgendwie
ein paar leute hören dazu
man findet euch die sich wirklich mal
hinsetzen und sagen okay wir müssen
jetzt kampagnen machen wir müssen wir
müssen müssen wir setzen somit den
fachleuten tisch
ja natürlich sonst wäre ich nicht
hingekommen
sie fordern zwar mehr ich dass
polizeibeamte und so weiter aber wir
brauchen zeit gleich auch den
rechtsstaat und da dürfe nicht über das
ziel hinaus gehen wir müssen uns
vernünftig überlegen wo können wir
einsparen wo können wir es verbessern
welche leute müssen rechtzeitig von
jugendrichter das sind die
geschlechtlichen es passiert
[Musik]